was passiert dann wie genau laufen atem
bis 1 bis 3 ab und wie geht es danach
weiter wie kommen wir zum mars genauso
habe ich das erste arte muss wieder
beendet und falls sie das noch nicht
gesehen habt dann könnt ihr das jetzt
hier oben nachholen und dann wieder
hierhin zurück kommen ich geh jetzt
einfach mal davon aus dass ihr das erste
video gesehen und jetzt ganz viele
fragen habt zum beispiel wie genau
laufen denn die artemis missionen ab und
wie viele sind geplant wo wir die nasa
genau eigentlich landen und wann wird
die erste frau den mond betreten das
erfahrt ihr alles in diesem video hier
dem zweiten teil unserer artemis reihe
und hinter all diesen fragen steht der
division je früher wir auf dem mond
landen desto schneller kommen wir auch
zum mars und um den mars geht es dann im
dritten und vorerst letzten video
unserer reihe als abonniert den kanal
und activity glocke damit ihr das nicht
verpasst
[Musik]
unser ziel ist es also menschen zurück
auf den mond zu bringen dort eine erste
basis zu errichten und mit dem wissen
dass wir dabei gewinnen zum mars zu
fliegen
aktuell sind konkret drei missionen zum
mond geplant und um die geht es auch in
diesem video hier artemis 1 2 und 3 und
je nachdem wie erfolgreich die missionen
sind sollen dann noch weitere artemis
mission und folgen die besiedlung des
mondes um für den mast üben bezeichnet
die nasa als mutmaßt programm atem ist
der erste schritt in diesem plan und der
läuft so ab
das ziel von artemis 1 ist es erst
einmal daten zu sammeln und zu gucken ob
das sls und orion überhaupt
einsatzbereit sind
denn wir vielleicht noch aus teil 1 ist
gestaltet sich die entwicklung sagen wir
mal schwierig los geht's vom kennedy
space center aus wo übrigens auch die
apollo-missionen starteten atem ist 1
läuft komplett unbemannt ab die mission
ist ein reiner testflug das sls story
und in die umlaufbahn des mondes dort
fliegt das raumschiff dann in einer
elliptischen form und einem ganz
speziellen orbit um den mond herum
danach startet und seine triebwerke um
der anziehung des mondes wieder zu
entkommen fliegt in richtung erde tritt
dort in die atmosphäre ein öffnet seine
fallschirme und schlägt auf dem wasser
auf und dann wird die kapsel auch wieder
eingesammelt und das soll stand jetzt
und wir drehen das gerade mitte märz
2021 noch ende diesen jahres passieren
ein genaues datum gibt es noch nicht das
hängt davon ab wann sls und fertig
werden wenn ich wetten müsste dann würde
ich eher auf 2022 setzen
dieses video wird übrigens unterstützt
von euch von page ich will das noch mal
ganz kurz sagen je mehr leute uns auf
paypal unterstützen desto weniger
werbung müssen wir in den videos machen
und mir bewusst dass das ja auch
irgendwo werbung ist aber leider müssen
wir irgendwo die rechnung bezahlen
deswegen weil ich das auch noch mal
gesagt haben danke euch eure
unterstützung
[Musik]
artemis 2 ist vom ablauf her sehr
ähnlich zu artemis 1 mit dem kleinen
aber feinen unterschied dass menschen
mit an bord sind nachdem das sls
gestartet ist dauert es nur acht minuten
bis sich orion von der trägerrakete
gelöst
daraufhin wird kurz das antriebsmodul
gezündet um orion in einen stabilen
orbit der erde zu bringen indem die
vierköpfige crew erst einmal durchatmen
kann bevor es weiter zum mond geht
werden wir astronautinnen und
astronauten das raumschiff neu
kalibrieren und die systeme überprüfen
auch beim start auch nichts schief
gegangen ist
während des fluges im erdorbit werden
vor allem aber auch die
lebenserhaltungssysteme von orion
getestet und die vitalwerte astronauten
genauestens überprüft wenn dann alle
systeme startklar sind und das wovon
nasa us mission control center kommt
dann wird das antriebsmodul von orion
erneut gestartet um die erde gänzlich
hinter sich zu lassen
hier kommt es auf exaktes timing an da
man nur so in den genau richtigen orbit
des mondes eintreten kann
außerdem schickt dieser orbit das
raumschiff dann nach dem rundflug auch
automatisch wieder zurück zur erde
das antriebsmodul die so genannte update
stage wird jetzt abgestoßen und lässt
die astronauten im orion raumschiff für
einige tage im all zurück bis sie dann
beim mond angekommen sind
vorher werden die astronauten allerdings
noch die manövrierfähigkeit von uri und
testen indem sie an diese abgestoßen apa
stage einmal heran und wieder wegfliegen
das sind sehr wichtige daten die unter
anderem auch noch für artemis 3 und das
doping am gateway gebraucht werden
übrigens wird das raumschiff nur während
dieses manövers von den astronauten
kontrolliert ansonsten wird es von der
erde aus gesteuert oder liegt sogar
komplett autonom ab einer gewissen
entfernung zur erde endet dann auch die
reichweite von gps und anderen tracking
satelliten weshalb man ab hier auf das
deep space network zurückgreifen muss
das klingt nicht nur ziemlich cool das
sind vor allem riesige radioantennen auf
der erde mit deren hilfe man zum
beispiel auch mit den rovern auf dem
mars kommunizieren kann
also es ist auch ziemlich cool mit hin-
und rückflug soll die mission insgesamt
zehn tage dauern
stattfinden soll die aktuell irgendwann
2023 aber auch dieses datum ist ohne
gewähr
denn die termine haben sich schon
geändert und können das auch noch in
zukunft weiter tun
[Musik]
artemis 3 ist das worauf alle warten
die mission wird quasi die mondlandung
2.0
damit hier alles reibungslos abläuft
müssen wir erst einmal wissenschaftliche
geräte materialien roboter und fahrzeuge
auf den mond bringen und das ist gar
nicht so einfach denn man kann ja nicht
einfach alles in das raumschiff mit den
astronauten quetschen den cargo länder
von blue origin kennt ihr vielleicht
noch aus dem letzten video solche lernen
da sollen mit hilfe des gateway dann die
nötigen teile vorab auf dem mond
platzieren
dafür nutzt die nasa größtenteils
private unternehmen wie blue origin und
space ex und so ähnlich soll es dann
auch auf dem mars ablaufen um den ersten
siedlern das überleben zu ermöglichen
der flug zum mond verläuft fast genauso
wie es bei artemis 2 erprobt wurde
doch beim mond angekommen wird es dann
schon etwas anspruchsvoller denn
eigentlich sollte hier jetzt das selbst
zusammengesetzte gateway auf die
astronauten warten an dem sie andocken
und in einen länder umsteigen können der
sie dann auf dem mond landen soll
doch wie wir schon im letzten video
erklärt haben kann es sein dass es nicht
so ohne weiteres möglich sein wird denn
das gateway hat arge probleme bei
finanzierungen und konstruktion weshalb
es eventuell einfach nicht rechtzeitig
fertig wird und dann muss die nasa
umplanen
eventuell wird dann der länder wie bei
den apollo missionen mit dem raumschiff
einfach mitgeschickt aktuell gibt es
dazu aber noch keine konkreten aussagen
von der nasa auf zukünftige nato
missionen nach artemis 3 soll das
gateway dann aber auf jeden fall wie
geplant einsatzbereit sein
wenn das mit dem gateway aber trotz
allem so klappen sollte dann steigt ein
teil der besatzung dort in den länder um
und wird zur oberfläche des mondes
geflogen
die anderen beiden crewmitglieder
bleiben im gateway und unterstützen die
mission von dort aus ein großer vorteil
vom gateway ist übrigens dass es den
orbit wechseln kann und so fast jeder
bereich des mondes von den ländern
angeflogen werden kann
das war so zum beispiel bei den apollo
missionen noch nicht möglich bis 3 wird
der südpol anvisiert auf dem mond
angekommen beginnt dann die eigentliche
mission die nasa hat hierfür 7
missionsziele definiert erstens man
möchte verstehen wo und warum sich
wasser auf der oberfläche angesammelt
hat und wie man es nutzen kann
zweitens ist es natürlich ein ziel
experimente auf der oberfläche
durchzuführen dazu gehören zum beispiel
proben die entnommen werden sowie auch
späteren missionen der bau einer
richtigen mondbasis
drittens die nase will mehr über die
entstehung des mondes herausfinden
viertens erhoffen sich die
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
neue erkenntnisse über den einfluss von
sonne und mond aufeinander sowie auf
deren gemeinsame vergangenheit fünfmal
möchte die prozesse die auf dem mond
stattfinden besser verstehen sechs man
möchte vom mond aus teile des universums
untersuchen um eine neue perspektive zu
erlangen und zu guter letzt möchte man
noch die risiken der planetenforschung
besser einschätzen und fehler vermeiden
lernen
generell gelten diese ziele
wahrscheinlich nicht nur für artemis
drei sondern können mehr als leitfaden
des gesamten programms gesehen werden
wie genau diese ziele jedoch erfüllt
werden sollen ist aktuell noch nicht
genau festgelegt was wir aber jetzt
schon wissen ist dass nach der
mondlandung proben entnommen werden
sollen
dafür wird unter anderem der ice bohrer
prime one mit geschickt mit dessen hilfe
man das eis auf dem mond genauer
untersuchen möchte
der aufenthalt auf dem mond wird mehrere
tage dauern und geschlafen wird im
länder
wer genau als erster mensch nach über 50
jahren wieder den mond betreten darf das
steht noch nicht fest es wird allerdings
einer von diesen 18 letten artemis
astronautinnen und astronauten seien
unter denen befindet sich übrigens auch
die erste frau die den mond betreten
wird nach abschluss der mission und mit
den neuen erkenntnissen und proben an
bord geht es dann zurück zum gateway und
anschließend zur erde atem ist rein
sollte eigentlich noch 2024 stattfinden
aber der neue chef der nasa ist ihr sieg
gab vor kurzem bekannt dass das budget
für eine mondlandung 2024 nicht
ausreichend werde jersey erklärte aber
präsident biden unterstützte das
programm und man halte an den zielen und
der mission planung weiter fest nur wie
weit sich artemis drei jetzt
letztendlich verschieben wird und ob das
auswirkungen auf atems 1 und 2 hat das
wissen wir aktuell noch nicht nach atem
ist 3 wird es dann aber richtig spannend
ab dann soll es jedes jahr mindestens
eine bemannte mond-mission geben
währenddessen soll das gateway immer
weiter ausgebaut werden um es für
missionen zum mars bereit zu machen
bis 2028 möchte man dann auch einen
wissenschaftlichen außenposten auf dem
mond errichtet haben in dem man sich bis
zu 45 tage lang aufhalten können soll
das finde ich das coolste einer gesamten
mission die basis soll dann in zukunft
stück für stück ausgebaut werden quasi
sowie die iss am anfang aber im
gegensatz weiß es
setzt das artemis programm vermehrt auf
private unternehmen wie zb beim bau der
luna länder
dadurch soll dann auch ein weg für
private unternehmen zum mond geebnet
werden die dort dann eigene gebäude und
sogar vielleicht eine eigene wirtschaft
errichten können und hier wird mich mal
eure meinung interessieren findet ihr es
gut dass private unternehmen auf dem
mond kommen und dort dann auch
wirtschaft betreiben schreibt mir das
gerne mal unten in die kommentare und
videos hier noch nicht vorbei aber falls
ihr noch mehr dazu erfahren wollt dann
könnt ihr euch dieses video hier oben
anschauen da reden wir darüber wie so
eine basis gebaut werden könnte
okay wir wissen jetzt wie die ersten
drei artemis missionen ungefähr ablaufen
werden
natürlich gibt es noch ganz ganz viele
kleine zwischenschritte und kleinere
missionen die wir jetzt leider nicht
erwähnen konnten weil es einfach den
rahmen dieses videos hier komplett
gesprengt hätte aber für mich stellt
sich jetzt immer noch eine große frage
was dann wie kommen wir nach atem ist
zum mars und sollen wir das überhaupt
tun warum reichen uns nicht aus und was
genau bringt euch die ihr dieses video
hier gerade schaut eine mission zum mars
eigentlich all das wird thema des
dritten und vorerst noch einmal letzten
videos unserer artemis reihe
vergesst nicht den kanal zu abonnieren
um das nicht zu verpassen und
unterstützt uns bei petri on oder doktor
watson tv wenn ihr dieses video vor
allen anderen sehen wollt und wenn die
uns unterstützen wollt damit wir
weiterhin solche videos wie dieses hier
machen können danke euch fürs zuschauen
und bleibt immer neugierig war cedric